[SOFT PIANO MUSIC]
RAEGAN KELLY JOHNSON:
Archives, to me, mean stories.
Stories that are told
that can connect the past
to the present.
And I think that is why it's
just so important that we
continue to fund
programs such as this,
so that we can just have
the opportunity to continue
to tell this narrative.
DAN LINKE: ARCH stands
for Archives Research
and Collaborative History.
And it is a pilot
program to bring students
from the historically black
colleges and universities
to Princeton for a week to
learn about archival practice.
ALEXIS ANTRACOLI: We're
doing a little bit
of lecture and
discussion, activities,
where they can do some hands-on
work with our collections.
So they're learning about how
archival research is done.
And we're also talking
about critiques
of the archival
profession, and bringing
in social justice critiques.
MADISON WASHINGTON:
Interpretation changes,
depending on the perspective,
depending on the person.
So if I'm able to go back to
something that was read 20
years ago, and bring a new
look onto it, then that's --
not having that will be
a missed opportunity.
So I think archives
are important to have,
because you're able
to go back and see
what was being discussed,
what was being looked at,
what was being done.
Bring a new
interpretation to it.
TONY BOUNDS: These
documents, these artifacts,
objects, they're from
particular periods.
And these particular
periods evoke
particular social evolution,
whether it's the civil rights
movement, whether it's
the antebellum period,
whether it's American
Reconstruction.
It's a glimpse into the past.
And in many instances,
it's a glimpse into today,
because every day,
we make history.
KIMBERLY MONROE: Archives
are vital to the existence
of Africana people
in this world.
With archives, we're
able to make a connection
to our descendants
because, in a way,
they've met us
through the archives.
So it's like all
of these historical
and present and future
moments are tied together.
ANNE JARVIS: Working
together with colleagues
from historically black
colleges and universities
on this program has meant
that we are providing students
with practical
ways in which they
can work on their archives back
in their home institutions.
SARAH TROTTY: So many
students don't know much
about the archival field.
So I feel it's
important for them
to have the experience to at
least have a look, a real close
look, at what archival
work provides.
Whether they're
interested in history
or interested in visual art,
or interested in writing,
they'll see the
connectivity, they'll
see the chance to
preserve, archive
those things that are very
important to cultural history.
KIMBERLY MONROE: What
we're doing here today,
and what we've done
all week, is only
the beginning of
what I like to call
the revolution of archives.
As scholars, as archivists,
as communication experts, what
we do for the world is to make
sure that everyone has a voice,
is to make sure that we're
not losing that voice,
and making sure that
everyone's voice is heard.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[SOFT ROCK MUSIC]